تويتر ال منصه التي باتت تتخبط في العديد
من العواصف منذ استحواذ الملياردير
الامريكي ايرون ماسك عليها اكتوبر الماضي
والجديد محللون يتوقعون انه بحلول السابع
عشر من يناير العام المقبل ان يصبح فيه
الى الماسك المؤثر رقم واحد على تويتر في
حال بقي حسابه
المتابعين بنفس الوتيره همم فعليا حساب
ماسك على تويتر له 120 مليون متابع ما
يجعله بالفعل ثاني اكبر الحسابات متابعه
على تويتر بعد حساب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق باراك اوباما الذي يتابعه 130
مليون شخص وفي عقاب الزياده الفلكيه لعدد
متابعيه منذ شرائه منصه تويتر يقول خبراء
الاحصاء بموقع الشرطه بلاي ده الذي يقوم
بتحليل البيانات من الصف التواصل
الاجتماعي ان ماسك سيصل حتما الى الموت
المرتبه الاولى وسوف تكون تلك لحظه غير
مسبوقه ولكن في حال اصبح ماسك المدير
التنفيذي لتويتر ومؤثره الابرز في الوقت
ذاته ماذا يعني ذلك المعلق المختص في شؤون
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي نافارا قال ان
ماسك يمتلك شخصيه مشاكسه واستفزازيه
للغايه وبالنسبه للعلامات التجاريه ربما
ينظر اليها على انه خطير اما كيت بيتشريل
المستشاره في مجال التقنيات الناشئه فاكدت
ان دمج شخصيه المدير التنفيذي مع شخصيه
المنصه يعرض الحياديه او التعدديه للخطر